kathy boyd will be making his first
start since
april 29th and big key for him has been
his first pitch strikes which have alway
almost been about 73 here's the one
two ripped to third and on a short hop
castro beautiful play and he throws him
out
what a play for a guy who makes his
first start
at third base this year wait how huge is
that right there
you know you get to be three and two and
i mean the lead off hitter you don't
want to start
with a double down the line he throws a
fastball right there hal castro
in replace of candelario makes a great
diving stop right there and keeps the
dangerous
with mary field off the bases brady
singer who had one of the best starts of
his young career
last time he was on this mound he's
confident as always
high intense he's a guy's a strike
thrower he likes his two-seam fastball
slider and there's a called third strike
not surprised the bases are loaded
scopes singled willie castro was hit by
a pitch and then akeel badou just walked
the 01 is a fastball hit on the ground
to the third baseman alberto goes across
the diamond
in time to get grinder tigers leave the
bases loaded
he's aggressive i mean he's up there to
swing the bat
just you know i don't i'm not walking i
you know i mean
certainly yes of course you take a walk
but he's aggressive and that's where
matthew boy can play into that and try
to throw him
something that he's gonna have to chase
or hit weekly
hits it sharply to third castro to
second the turn
in time the double play to end the
inning
a job well done by matthew boyd and the
defense behind him
on valley sports
you know in his last time there it is he
had he took his 16th
straight called looking strikeout first
time and now this one makes him 17 and
that's tied for second most
in major league baseball so he needs the
slogan if you don't hack
he'll make you pack he'll send you back
either one of those there it is at the
location right there
the one two way even a miss four
strikeouts for brady singer he had eight
his first time against detroit
yeah a good slider right here by brady
singer gets
ahead and uh it was all set up by the
the previous pitch where it was
out over the plate what a nice job
they've done that yeah a little
surprising to me maybe
jonathan scope pokes one to center
taylor will watch it go by
all the way to the wall this says triple
written all over it
scope kicks it up a notch
and a lead off triple for jonathan scope
in the tigers four
[Applause]
now nothing like a leadoff triple that's
for sure you know
a slider out over the plate jonathan
scope hits it into the left center
gap there after the first time where we
said he saw the ball
deep and then and hit it to right field
so now he's using the entire field
these are the moments that tigers have
been working on getting that runner home
from third by making
contact goodrum's short cautious lead at
first the strike one
swinging a line driving to center field
will it drop taylor on the run he dives
he won't get it
scoped tagging and he will score and how
about nico goodrum
he read it all the way and scoots first
to third what a great job
tigers take a one-nothing lead well good
swing first of all anytime you make a
good swing in that situation
and taylor looked like i'll tell you
what i thought taylor was going to
overplay the ball again and would get by
him but he
was somehow able to smother the ball
yeah in a big inning put up a big
crooked number here you know don't just
uh be satisfied with just the one and
2-2
line to left and that's going to drop in
front of ben and tendy
all the way to third goes willy castro
an rbi
single for aquila badou makes it
two-nothing tigers
that's the one right there you know
instead of trying to do too much
just doing it getting the pitch that you
want
choking up and just slapping it over the
left that's just a great job of hitting
by
akil badu i got nobody out good start to
the inning still first and third
there he goes to right field
dropping it's in there and badou all the
way to third
round and round they go here in the
fourth
keep first a third of them all night
long yeah good good for grayson grinder
this is a slider it was a good pitch to
run on
but good for grayson grinder just you
know he's button in the first couple of
pitches then takes the fastball then
doesn't try to do too much
gets the the slider over the plate and
just pokes it into right
field and with badou off on the pitch
easily makes it into third merrifield
lopez still in double play depth this
will be the ninth pitch of the at-bat
on the way swing a fly ball left field
will it be deep enough to get badoo home
ben attending makes the catch but dude
tags and he will score easily
sacrifice fly for robbie grossman
terrific at bat four-nothing tigers here
in the fourth
yes sir put the ball in play that ball
got a lot of the plate was the right guy
to have up with the bases loaded though
isn't it you know he knows he's going to
wait and be patient
right center that's going to split the
outfield
and that's going to drive home all three
runs
but due can motor easily scores
grossman's got himself
a three-run triple and a huge inning for
the tigers
here in the fifth yeah baby couldn't get
it out fast enough
chef just you know he's gonna be patient
and he's he's you're gonna have to throw
him a strike with the bases loaded and
he got a good pitch to hit
he stays hot drills it into right center
clears the bases i like the way he turns
it on at second base
you can see him cuts it short right
there boy semo that's base running 101
right there
now the one two wow yeah
see ya expecting that one no it wasn't
that's a 71 mile an hour change up and
it froze
andrew ben and tendy for the final out
in the sixth
five punch-outs for matthew boyd that is
a thing of beauty
matthew boyd his night is over after six
innings but
only gave up four hits four singles but
he had all four pitches
working for him that slow curve ball the
high fastball we see right here the
change up you know there's a good change
up right there and to end the inning
uh in the sixth yeah big looping slow
breaking ball to ben and tendy
he's not waiting for that thought maybe
it was going to be over his head but it
just dropped right at the last minute
and caught it so
all four pitches again working for
matthew boyd so
wonderful outing especially coming back
after that left knee tendonitis
for three with a pop-up strikeout and
fly out we're in the eighth
seven nothing detroit big joe with the
pitch to
jorge solaire and a swing and a drive to
left that's deep that's way back
and that ball is long gone home run
jorge solaire so that's his first in a
long long time his third of the year and
the royals
on the scoreboard with a three-run home
run
105 miles off the bat
tail of the tape 410 feet
three straight pinch hit at bats in the
white sox series
and that is into center field left
center field and that's down for a hit
so it is 7-4 and the tying run comes up
with one out
on the ground left side and bobbled
and everybody is safe
[Applause]
the royals how about that have a little
light
never over until it's over so
nico kind of took his eye off of it a
little bit
runner was going in front of him i mean
you know he's just distracted but one
slight bobble there's no way you're
going to get the runner
castro just standing there watching him
and now jorge solaire
into deep center field and off of
produce glove
and the royals are going to get three
and jorge soler
has driven in six and the royals have
tied it
in the ninth inning shot the house
and aj hinch that tightness he was
feeling
came to fruition that's the guy you
wanted at the plate solaire
and by golly first pitch he wasn't
messing around
watch this coming right at you solaire
4 20. but dude looked like he had it off
the end of his glove
two away it's up to robbie grossman the
one two
and he's in the right field
good room will score go crazy
grossman wins it for the tigers on a
one-two
bullet down the first baseline
[Applause]
yep they didn't know which one to do
they decided on the fastball
inside to robbie grossman and he turns
on it we talked about
right man at the right spot in that kind
of situation
he's going to give you a good quality
at-bat and there he does again and this
is a win
that the tigers just had to have after
that 7-0 lead was blown
and it feels a lot better to win this
one grossman came
through in the fifth and he comes up big
in the ninth